SIMULTANEOUSLY UKRAINE IS
LOOKING INTO THE ISSUE.
THEY HAVE A FULL-FLEDGED
INVESTIGATION.
HERE NOW WITH REACTION, SENATE
JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN
LINDSEY GRAHAM IS WITH US.
SENATOR, WE ARE LOSING 300
PEOPLE A WEEK BECAUSE OF OPIOID
ADDICTION IN THIS COUNTRY.
THEN WE HAVE SANCTUARY CITIES
AND STATES, WE HAVE VIOLENT
CRIMINALS THAT ARE RELEASED, AND
THEY CREATE, THEY COMMIT MORE
VIOLENT CRIMES.
I WOULD ARGUE, THEY WOULD ARGUE
IF IT WAS US THEY HAVE BLOOD ON
THEIR HANDS.
THEY ARE ACCOMPLISHES ACCOMPLICE
DO WHEN WE PROTECT THEM, AIDING
AND ABETTING CRIME.
HOW DOES THAT STOP?
>> THIS IS THE DEFINING ISSUE OF
THE ELECTION AMONG MANY.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS SAYING
IF YOU ARE A SANCTUARY CITY AND
YOU REFUSED TO WORK WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO TURN OVER
VIOLENT FELONS SO THEY CAN BE
INCARCERATED AND DEPORTED, IF HE
REFUSED TO HELP THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, WE ARE GOING TO CUT
OFF ALL FEDERAL FUNDS.
LET’S TAKE THAT TO THE BALLOT
BOX.
THERE ARE MEN AND WOMEN BEING
KILLED, RAPED AND MURDERED BY
FELONS AND SANCTUARY CITY, WHO
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT REFUSES TO
TURN OVER THE FELON TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
THEY STAY IN THE CITY AND THEY
MURDER AND KILL AND ROB AND TO
ME, THE PRESIDENT IS
DEAD RIGHT ABOUT THIS, THEY
SHOULD TAKE THIS TO BIDEN AND
BERNIE AND SAY, WHAT IS YOUR
POSITION ON THIS?
>> Sean: YOU HAVE KNOWN
JOE BIDEN FOR MANY, MANY YEARS,
YOU WORKED WITH HIM FOR MANY,
MANY YEARS.
WE SEE THE GAPS, WE SEE
RON JOHNSON’S COMMITTEE LOOKING
INTO BURISMA, A BILLION
DOLLARS, FIRE THE PROSECUTOR,
INVESTIGATING MY ZERO EXPERIENCE
ON WHO IS PAID MILLIONS.
I THINK WE WOULD GET A DIFFERENT
RESPONSE FROM THE DEMOCRATS.
BIDEN, MY HONEST OPINION, HIS
GAFFES ARE NOW OFFICIALLY VERY
ALARMING.
WHETHER HE IS UP TO THE DRIVE
COME OF THE TOUGHEST JOB IN THE
WORLD.
HE HAS A RECORD THAT WILL BE
COMPARED TO PRESIDENT TRUMP’S.
NOT VERY GOOD ON EITHER FOREIGN
POLICY OR ECONOMICALLY.
TELL US ABOUT THE JOE BIDEN YOU
KNOW AND THE ONE WHO WANTS OPEN
BORDERS IN SANCTUARY CITIES AND
FREE HEALTH CARE FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
SPEAK OF THE JOE BIDEN I KNOW I
BEEN A DISASTER ON NATIONAL
SECURITY.
IT WAS JOE BIDEN WHO CONVINCED
OBAMA TO PULL ALL OF THE TROOPS
OUT OF IRAQ.
IT IS JOE BIDEN WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE RISE OF ISIS
MORE THAN ANY SINGLE POLITICIAN.
JOE BIDEN SUPPORTED THE IRAN
NUCLEAR AGREEMENT.
JOE BIDEN ALLOWS ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS FREE HEALTH CARE.
JOE BIDEN WOULD CANCEL THE
PROGRAM IN PLACE IF YOU ARE
SEEKING ASYLUM YOU HAVE TO WAIT
IN MEXICO.
THE BIGGEST THING
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS DONE IS NOT
JUST BUILD WALL.
REMEMBER SIX MONTH AGO WHEN
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WERE COMING HERE WANTING TO GET
CAUGHT CLAIMING ASYLUM AND WE
HAD TO TURN THEM LOOSE IN OUR
COUNTRY, THEY NEVER SHOWED UP TO
THE HEARING?
IT WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO
CONVINCED MEXICO TO ALLOW US TO
KEEP THEM IN MEXICO UNTIL THEY
ARE HEARING SO THEY DON’T RUN
AROUND AND GET LOOSE IN OUR
COUNTRY.
THAT IS THE BIGGEST CHANGE IN
IMMIGRATION IN THE LAST 30 OR 40
YEARS, AND JOE BIDEN SAYS HE
WOULD TERMINATE THAT PROGRAM.
>> Sean: FREE HEALTH CARE,
AMNESTY, OPEN BORDERS.
WOW.
90% OF AMERICA’S HEROIN COMES
FROM THERE.
THE PFIZER CORE, YOU ARE
BEGINNING YOUR PROCESS OF
INVESTIGATING THAT.
WE ARE WAITING FOR DURHAM, WE
ARE WAITING FOR
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR BUT THE
FISA COURT HAS SPOKEN OUT TODAY
WITH SOME VERY STRONG LANGUAGE.
WE WILL GET INTO THE DETAILS
COMING UP.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF THAT NEW
DEVELOPMENT TODAY, THE FISA
COURT SPEAKING OUT?
AND WILL BE EVER GET TO HEAR
FROM THE JUDGES THAT WERE LIED
TO?
>> HERE’S WHAT I THINK.
I THINK THE COURT HAS TO PROVE
TO THE PUBLIC AT LARGE THAT THEY
ARE CAPABLE OF DOING SOMETHING
ABOUT THE ABUSE THAT CAME THEIR
WAY.
HERE’S WHAT I’M TRYING TO FIND
OUT MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
IN JANUARY 2017, THE PRIMARY SUB
SOURCE SAY RUSSIA, WHO GAVE ALL
THE INFORMATION OF THE DOSSIER
TO CHRISTOPHER STEELE TELLS THE
FBI THAT IT IS A BUNCH OF
BARTOK.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
AFTER THAT.
HOW DID COMEY AND McCABE NOT
KNOW THAT THE ENTIRE CASE FELL
APART?
I DON’T BELIEVE IT IS POSSIBLE
AT ALL FOR THE HIGHER-UPS NOT TO
BE TOLD THAT THE ENTIRE CASE
COLLAPSED IN JANUARY 2017.
>> Sean: TOP OF THE FISA
WARRANT.
I’VE BEEN TOLD, I’VE NEVER SEEN
ONE.
IT SAYS VERIFIED.
WE KNOW NOW IT IS UNVERIFIABLE.
MULTIPLE WARNINGS.
BACK TO OCTOBER, PREMEDITATED
FRAUD.
>> CAN I ADD SOMETHING TO THAT?
WE KNOW THE PERSON WHO PREPARED
THE INFORMATION SAID IT WASN’T
RELIABLE.
THE PERSON WHO GAVE
CHRISTOPHER STEELE THE ENTIRE
INFORMATION SAID TO THE FBI AND
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, THIS IS B
NEVER MEANT IT TO BE USED IT TO
GET A WARRANT.
WE KNOW THAT AND THEY WENT AHEAD
AND GOT TWO MORE WARRANTS AFTER
THEY KNEW THAT.
>> Sean: PREMEDITATED FRAUD,
DENYING INDIVIDUALS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO SPY ON